welcome to this video playing maroon see
50 km c5 he induced the Sicilian with
this name okay so which line but some
dough for this Kalashnikov line similar
to this rationing cough but not quite
and of course I have forgotten the
theory I think I think there should be
seven was what I looked at some time ago
but I already have forgotten anything
Knight f6 and I have probably Knight f6
attacking attacking here when you fall
yeah I needs to address that I think ok
took just took it yell Quinn Texan
problem looks like the most natural way
to recapture night c4 I can just take
should I play night before
he just has a hard time to prevent the
caption that ok it's not the end of the
world anyway I don't need to play night
before with him
yeah pin and win but I hope the wind
part doesn't apply here I can just
complete development I hope yeah now his
maybe maybe intending to play at four at
some point but it's not really a thread
I can I can play this prepared e5 I
could have played d5 immediately but I
wasn't sure what I actually wanted to do
is after after this to capture with the
rook this is strange what is he doing on
hmm g5 on g5 he needs to take on d5
Bishop g3 I take a form i take evil you
cannot take twice f5f for Windsor wins
the bishop or maybe yes checks on g6
okay yeah but it's fine for me anyway if
it takes twice on if I mean
yeah I think I should have taken on d5
just on g5 take only five okay if I'm
retreat now I shouldn't just take him
down what now squinty five helpful Zack
now he needs to get into a self pin I'll
put the King on the edge phone your
exchange means this is even nicer what's
now deform yep
yeah click on the default him to t2
okay this end game with two pawns quite
much and he's not catching the bishop
Jeff wait reasons yeah I we must take on
d5 here he needs to take on d5 now it's
it's nice for black anyway but it's not
it's not the end of our Knight takes c3
here didn't see that light takes III m I
only thought that time this would be
nice on on general grounds even even
simply not f4 is an interesting move but
ok this is a tactical way
yeah winning opponent this is weak the
cop doesn't see anything agreed so it
seems to be okay minus one point
something the I didn't see Knight c3 I
just thought okay everything else fails
I can play even have six or something
but so it's strategically okay or this
one and I really don't know but it's
it's nice I have all I have nice pieces
and the King isn't the problem with
Jafar okay thanks for watching